we've got Taryn outside actually this
might comer from the club here in the
st. Louis chess club to talk about the
tournament that you guys can get in on
the action hmm yes Jen thank you i am
here with Mike comer of the st. Louis
chess club and the st. Louis open is
coming up so you want to explain to
people what that's all about sure the
bill right st. Louis open will take
place April as 17 through the 19th it
will feature a twelve thousand dollar
prize fund the open section will be a
feed a rated and it will feature top
prize of a two thousand dollars past
winners have been hakura Nakamura
alejandro ramirez and wesley slow is
actually a two-time defending champion
of the event and there's twenty prizes
and there's also an under 2,000 section
which with features a top prize of one
thousand dollars that's great and people
can still register and get involved yes
you have until april fifteenth to
register and lock in a hundred dollar
entry fee after that it will go up to a
120 dollars and space is limited this
year so so get your entry fiza in early
at st. Louis chess club morgue awesome
and for those of you that don't know
mike is also a star here at the club in
his own right he is the 1998 missouri
state champion and he's also a youtube
sensation so for those of you that
haven't checked out the youtube channel
the st. Louis chess club youtube channel
you just sort of explain to people the
classes and things that they can find
there sure yeah you can google meaning
of life revealed and that will come up
with my video there you can also go to
youtube and search in a chest lecture or
chess club and we have over 500 videos
on our youtube channel and it's a lot of
fun and you know we got grandmasters
doing a great lectures yeah and what
kind of classes do you teach here at the
club sure I teach the beginner breakdown
class tuesdays at six-thirty and they're
also featured on the YouTube channel so
there you have it even if you can't get
down to the chess club of st. Louis you
can also tune in on their YouTube
channel again just just search for st.
Louis chess club and you can find Mike's
videos among other
things there too as well thank you very
much we'll send it back down to Jenn
thank you Taran yeah great and you know
my Commerce also one of the featured
instructors on the very popular seen it
was just called YouTube channel yes he
is really have all the grandmasters and
residents and I might giving lessons as
well I've actually attended a couple of
his lectures here he's got this booming
you learn anything yeah that you can be
a great presenter if your voice carries
to the fall those ends of the room